انتشار شابا على قيد الحياه فيها بعد 12
يوما تحت الركام وجدال في تركيا بشان
المباني المقاومه للزلازل
واشنطن تنتهي من تدريب مجموعه من الجنود
الاوكرانيين والعربيه ترصد برامج اعداد
المجندين الاوكرانيين في بريطانيا
تقارير عن احتمال وصول طائرات الروسيه
متطوره الى قاعده عسكريه تكتيكيه في ايران
مهمتها تنفيذ عمليات جويه مفاجئه
[موسيقى]
طب ثم طابت اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى نشره
الاخبار من العربيه تمكنت فرق الانقاذ في
تركيا من انتشار شاب حيا من تحت الانقاض
امس بعد 278 ساعه منزل وذلك فيها طايق
جنوب تركيا
[موسيقى]
وبعد 12 يوما من وقوع الزلزال الذي اودى
بحياه اكثر من 45 الف شخص في سوريا وتركيا
يتزايد الغضب في تركيا بعد انهيار الاف
المنازل لقيله انها مقاومه للزلازل ففي
خطايتهم عشرات الاشخاص السلطات المحليه
بتهون في انشاء في انشاءات دون المستوى
وباستخدام مواد رخيصه او غير مناسبه في
وقتنا افاد مسؤولون من قطاع الانشاء بان
الكثير من المباني تخالف قوانين البناء
[موسيقى]
بعد كارثه الزلزال الذي ضرب سوريا وتركيا
تقوم الحكومه التركيه الان بتقييم الضرر
الماديه الذي لحق بالابنيه والبنى التحتيه
لتكون عمليه اعاده الاعمار الاكبر والاكثر
تكلفه في تاريخ تركيا
[موسيقى]
اكبر في تاريخ جمهوريه
قد تصل تكلفتها الى 100 مليار دولار
زلزال تركيا الحق ضررا جسيما باكثر من
مليون وسبعمائه الف بناء
عدا عن تضرر البنيه التحتيه العمليه
التاريخيه تشمل المباني السكنيه والمدارس
والمشافيك والمطارات والطرق السريعه بنك
الاستثمار جيبي مورجن قدر التكلفه الاوليه
للهياكل المدمره بخمسه وعشرين مليار دولار
ما يعادل 2.5% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
لتركيا
اكد المتحدث باسم مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه الدكتور سامر سامر الشطيلي وصولها
80 طن من المساعدات الاغاثيه المقدمه من
المملكه
لمتضرري الزلزال في شمال غرب سوريا
هذه جزء من المساعدات التي دخلت للشمال
شمال الغرب السوري شملت على
الحقيقه اطنان من
المساعدات المتعلقه بالامن الغذائي وكذلك
المساعدات المتعلقه
80 طن عباره عن عشر شاحنات
تحتوي كما ذكرت مواد غذائيه وايوائيه
وكذلك تحتوي على
ما يتعلق بنوازم المستلزمات لواء كالحقيبه
الايوائيه البطانيات وغيرها من الاشياء
التي يحتاجها كل من يكون في حاجه او يكون
الحقيقه في خيمه من الخيام
[موسيقى]
ضلينا بالشوارع يعني تقريبا ثلاثه اربعه
ايام والوضع كتير ماساوي جوا كانوا بعنتاب
الاصلاحي كهرمان مرعش انطاكيا يعني الوضع
كتير سيء وخاصه المعامله باتجاه السوريين
فتحوا لنا المعابر هلا ودخلنا على سوريا
نطمن على اهلنا
ولبين ما الله هيك يفرج علينا وتزول
المحنه
ونرجع ان شاء الله
وربع طلعنا عند بيتنا ما نقدر نسكن ببيتنا
والدوله حضرتنا عن بيتنا بيتنا ما نقدر
نسكن بيه طلعنا بالدين
وجينا على هنا وفتحت الباب
تركيا للعالم الزيارات كنا نايمين الصبح
الساعه اربعه الساعه اربعه اربعه وربع صار
الزلزال طلعنا برا يومين بالحدا
رجعنا على البيوت
صار لنا يوم الفاتحه الاجازه على سوريا
[موسيقى]
مع الازمه الانسانيه افدى المرصد السوري
بوقوع اشتباكاتهم بين قوات النظام وفصائل
معارضه للمره الاولى منذ الزلزال المرصد
قال ان النظام قصف مدينه الاتارب ومشارف
قريتين في محافظه حماه كما حدثت اشتباكات
قرب مدينه سراقب
تحدثت وسائل اعلاما تابعه للنظام السوري
عن مقتل خمسه 53 شخصا في هجوم لداعش في
ريف حمص الشرقي واشارت وسائل الاعلام من
محليه الى ان الهجوم تم بالاسلحه الخفيفه
والمتوسطه استهدف مدنيين في باديه السخنه
بريف حمص الشرقي من جهته تحدث المرصد
السوري عن مقتل 46 مدنيا في هذا الهجوم
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
جمهوريون يحملون اداره بايدن المسؤوليه عن
عواقب عن العواقب بجراءه خطه الانسحاب من
افغانستان
حياكم الله التقت وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه انا لنا بوزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان على هامش
مؤتمر ميونخ للامن واكدت على اهميه شراكه
الالمانيه السعوديه في مجال الطاقه
المتجدده كالهيدروجين الاخضر واضافت انها
ناقشت مع وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الازمه
اليمنيه والخطر المتزايد من تصعيد النوويا
ايراني في المنطقه
المتحدث باسم البنتاجون الجنرال
ان القوات الامريكيه عنها الدوره تدريبيه
موسعه لمجموعه اولى تضم اكثر من 600 جندي
اوكراني في منطقه جرافي نوفيرا في المانيا
واضاف رايدر ان التدريبات العسكريه
المشتركه استمرت خمسه اسابيع تقريبا وشملت
مهاما اساسيه ومناورات بما فيها التدريب
على المركبه القتاليه ام اثنين برادلي
على مدى خمسه اسابيع يخضع المجندون
الاوكرانيون لبرا لبرنامج تدريب تشرف عليه
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه لتطوير مهارات
الاوكرانيين القتاليه البرنامج يشمل تدريب
الجنود على حرب المدن والشوارع واساليب
البقاء على قيد الحياه واسعاف الجرحى
كاميرا العربيه كانت حاضره في معسكر
التدريب في شماليه انجلترا
جنود اوكرانيون كانهم في معركه حقيقيه ضد
القوات الروسيه يتحركون ويطلقون الرصاصه
في خنادق واقعيه هؤلاء في تدريب تشرف عليه
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه وكاميرا العربيه
كانت حاضره لالتقاط جزء من هذه التدريبات
العسكريه لتطوير مهارات الاوكرانيين
القتاليه منذ 2014 والجيش البريطاني بخبره
الواسعه يساعد اوكرانيا على اعاده بناء
قوتها وهذه الدوره التدريبيه للاوكرانيين
في شمال انجلترا هي ضمن التزام المملكه
المتحده لدعم اوكرانيا في مواجهه روسيا
على مدى خمسه اسابيع يخضع المجندون
الاوكرانيون لبرنامج تدريب يمنحهم الادوات
القتاليه الاساسيه في مواقف سيواجهونها
عند عودتهم الى اوكرانيا
اظهر المتدربون حافزا جيدا للغايه ومن
الواضح انهم يتعلمون بسرعه من خلال
البرنامج التدريبي ويتقدمون بشكل جيد
للغايه
مراحل التدريب المجندين الاوكرانيين تشمل
حرب المدن والشوارع واساليب البقاء على
قيد الحياه والنجاه الى جانب تقديم
الاسعافات الطبيه للجرحى حتى يكتسب
المتدربون المهارات اللازمه للدفاع عن
سياده بلدهم كما يقولون
لا نعرف الى اين سيتم ارسالنا بمجرد
الانتهاء من هذه الدوره التدريبيه ولكننا
سنكون مستعدين للذهاب الى اي منطقه
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه وسعت نطاق برنامج
التدريب الاوكرانيين منذ بدء الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه وتتوقع تطوير قدرات
اكثر من 20 الف مجند هذا العام وتدريبهم
على استخدام الاسلحه الثقيله والفتاكه وهو
ضعف عدد العام الماضي مصطفى زارو العربيه
من شمال انجلترا
خلال كلمته في مؤتمر ميونخ للامن قال
الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون ان فرنسا
جاهزه مع الحلفاء لحرب طويله الامد في
اوكرانيا
في حربها الكارثيه على اوكرانيا روسيا
انتهت مواثيق الامم المتحده ومجلس الامن
بحربها ضد اوكرانيا كما تتحمل مسؤوليه
التداعيات السلبيه لحربها فساعه الحوار مع
روسيا لم تحم بعد بسبب تمسك بوتين بخيار
الحرب كما قابلت روسيا دعوات الحوار
باستهداف البنيه التحتيه الاوكرانيه
بالاضافه الى ان مجموعه باجنار تحولت الى
قوات رسميه بعد فشل الجيش الروسي في تحقيق
مكاسب
نشرت نيويورك تايمز صورا لاقمار صناعيه
تظهر وصول مقاتلات الروسيه متطوره لقاعده
جويه ايرانيه وقالت الصحيفه ان صور
الاقمار الصناعيه رصدت مجسما يشبه مقاتلات
سوخوي 35 الروسيه بالقرب من قاعده عسكريه
شيدتها ايران تحت الارض وكشفت عنها مؤخرا
واضافت الصحيفه الامريكيه ان الصور ربما
تشير الى ان ايران تحاول استخدام مجسم
بابعاد المقاتله الروسيه للتاكد من
امكانيه مرورها داخل الانفاق في القاعده
الجديده
فضحت الناشطه الحقوقيه الايرانيه مسيحه
لنجاه تجاوزا جديدا ارتكبته السلطات
الايرانيه بتسريحها معلمه في بلده قائم
شهر لنشرها فيديو تظهر فيه وهي تغني مع
طلابها الصغار
[موسيقى]
في تونس قال الرئيس هو قيس السعيد ان
الايقافات الاخيره لبعض السياسيين ورجال
اعمالا وقضاه معفيين من انما هي خطوه
تتعلق بالفساد والتامر والاستيلاء على
المال العام ولا علاقه لها بحريه التعبير
كمان طيب رجل الاعمال المثير للجدل يودع
السجن على خلفيه ياتوها من تتعلق بالتامر
على امن الدوله الداخليه والخارجيه التتبع
القضائي لا يتوقف عند لطيف بل يشمل
سياسيين محسوبين على حركه النهضه ورجال
اعمال واعلاميين وكذلك كوادر امنيه اما
نور الدين البحيري الرجل الثاني في حركه
النهضه وزير العدل الاسبق فيطبع الان في
السجن واتهم مواجهه اليها تسليم جوازات
سفر الى ارهابيين وتدليس احكام قضائيه
ووفائقه رسميه وفي الجانب الاعلامي من
القضيه تم الاحتفاظ نور الدين بوطار مدير
عام اذاعه موزاييك فاما الخاصه على خلفيه
جوانب تتعلق بتسيير المؤسسه ماليا واداريا
مع توجيه اسئله له حول خطها التحريري
خصومه هذه الشخصيات مع قيس سعيد تختلف
بدرجه الحده ودرجه الخطوره ايضا لكن الخيط
الناظمي بينها باستثناء القاضيين اما
البقيه فاعتقد ان ما يجمعها هو ما رشح من
اسباب روجت له الدوائر الرسميه حول مساله
المؤامره التي قيل انها حركت في منزل خيام
التركي
والشخصيه المحوريه لهذه المجموعه هو كمال
الطيف ويبدو انه هو النواه او الدائره
المركزيه لهذه المجموعه انصحت فعلا نظريه
المؤامره والتي لم يستطع الخطاب الرسمي
الى حد الان ان يبررها او ان يقنع بها
تقارير اعلاميه نقلت عن مراقبين للوضع في
افغانستان عن شروخ بدات بالظهور في لحمه
قياده طالبان خلافات لا تظهر للعلن الا
لمن يمحص في خطاب الشخصيات البارزه في
كابول وقندهار
افغانستان تنتقل من ازمه الى اخرى والقاسم
المشترك بين هذه الازمات هو قياده طالبان
وما يسري بينها من خلافات لا تظهر جليا
للعيان ولكن نتائجها وتاثيرها ينعكس على
شعب افغانستان الفقير الجائع اولى علامات
الشرخ هي البعد الجغرافي بين قياده الحركه
في معقلها الاصلي قندهار والقياده
السياسيه والاداريه في العاصمه كابول
فالقائد الاعلى الملا هبه الله اخوند زاده
ومستشاروه قابعون في جبال قندهار بعيدا عن
عاصمه البلاد وبالتالي هم بعيدون عن صوت
الشعب الافغاني الذين يديرون شؤونه عبر
الفتاوى كتلك التي منع التعليم الفتيات
وعملا النساء في المؤسسات الانسانيه
الدوليه
الوزراء التابعون للحركه والذين يمارسون
ما لديهم من سلطات قليله في كابول بداوا
يعبرون عن امتعادهم لو بشكل مبطن حيث القى
وزير الداخليه سراج الدين حقاني خطابا قال
فيه انه على طالبان تهدئه المواطنين
والتصرف بطريقه لا يكرهها الناس ويكرهون
معها الدين في اشاره الى القرارات
المتزمته التي فاقمت الفقر والجهل في
البلاد كما ان حقاني انتقد احتكار السلطه
الذي يضر بسمعه النظام باكمله مشيرا ولو
ضمنيا الى قله صلاحيات وعجز الوزراء في
كابول مقابل وجود كل خيوط السلطه بيد
اخوان زاده ومساعديه
مؤشرات قال مراقبون انها تدل على انشقاقات
وشيكه في حركه طالبان التي تدفع
السياساتها المتهوره البلاد الى المجاعه
انسنا ماسي العربيه
وجهها اعضاء جمهوريون من لجنه الرقابه
والمحاسبه بمجلس النواب الامريكي رساله
الى المجلس مجلس الامن القومي والخارجيه
الامريكيه والبنتاجون وهيئه الاركان
المشتركه للقوات المسلحه ووزاره الامن
الداخلي ووكاله التنميه الدوليه طلبوهم
فيها بتقديم الوثائق والمراسلات
والمعلومات الخاصه بخطوات الرئيس جو بايدن
المتعلقه بانسحاب القوات الامريكيه الفاشل
من افغانستان في عام
واعتبر النواب ان خطوات الاداره الامريكيه
اسفرت عن عواقب كارثيه على الامن القومي
الامريكي وفي المجال الانساني
اعلن البنتاجون اختتام عمليه استعاده حطام
المنطاد الصيني الذي اسقطته القوات
الامريكيه قباله سواحل ساوت كارولينا في
الرابع من فبراير الجاري وما زال الغموض
سيد الموقف بشان الاجسام المجهوله الهويه
التي كانت تحلق في الاجواء الكنديه
والامريكيه
بعد نحو اسبوعين على اسقاطه اختتمت عمليات
استرداد واستعاده الحطام من المنطاد
الصيني قباله سواحل حسب ما اعلن البنتاجون
فالقطع الاخيره منه ستنقل الى مختبر لمكتب
التحقيقات الفيدراليه في ولايه فيرجينيا
حيث يتم تحليلها ياتي ذلك بعد يوم على
كلمه للرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن وجهها
للامريكيين بشان الاجسام المجهوله
والمنطاد لم تقدم الكثير من المعلومات
لا نعرف حتى الان بالضبط ما هذه الاجسام
الثلاثه لكن لا يوجد الان ما يشير الى
انها مرتبطه ببرنامج تجسس الصيني او انها
كانت مركبات مراقبه من اي دوله اخرى
ولتعامل الحكومه الامريكيه مع هذه الاجسام
مجهوله الهويه في المستقبل من المتوقع
اصدار بروتوكولات جديده بشانها في القريب
العاجل ومشاركتها مع الكونغرس
سوف نتاكد من ان لدينا بعض القواعد
الجديده لكيفيه اتخاذنا القرارات في
المستقبل هذا لا يعني كما سمعت الرئيس
يقول البارحه انه لن تكون هناك عمليات
اسقاط اضافيه اذا كان يعتقد ان هناك
تهديدا مشروعا لسلامتنا وامرنا وجود
الاجسام مجهوله الهويه في الاجواء
الامريكيه شغل الراي العام وزاد الجدل حول
معرفه الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه وحتى
السابقه بوجودها
بحسب صحيفه وار ستريت جورنال فان دائره
صغيره من مسؤولين الاستخبارات في
البنداجون خلال اداره ترامب راقبت سلسله
من الاجسام الغامضه يشتبه الان في انها
مناطيد لكن لم يتم ابلاغ البيت الابيض
عنها لعدم وضوح ماهيتها انذاك
[موسيقى]
انا على درايه بالمقال لا اعرف مدى دقته
لقد رايت مثلا الوزير السابق اصبر كان
واضحا في التلفزيون انه لم يتم اطلاعه على
الامر لا اعلم هناك احتمال اننا لم نكن
نتتبع حقا البالونات البطيئه مثل الان
ومع استمرار الجدل حول هذه الاجسام
المجهوله والمنطاد الصيني تسارع اداره
بيضا لجمع المعلومات في ظل تزايد
الانتقادات والضغوط من قبل الجمهوريين
حسين العربيه واشنطن
[موسيقى]
نهايه النشره تذكيرهم بابرز العناوين
انتشار شاب على قيد الحياه في هاتاي بعد
12 يوما تحت الركام وجدل في تركيا بشان
المباني المقاومه للزلازل
واشنطن تنتهي من تدريب مجموعه من الجنود
الاوكرانيين والعربيه ترصد برامج اعداد
المجندين الاوكرانيين في بريطانيا
تقارير عن احتمال وصول طائرات الروسيه
المتطوره الى قاعده عسكريه تكتيكيه في
ايران مهمتها تنفيذ عمليات جويه مفاجئه
القاكم بعد قليل
[تصفيق]